we haven't played a crazy tick tock
video in a while well when i say while i
mean like we haven't played one in maybe
two days so here's one that went viral
here is a
person who identifies i think is both
trans and non-binary
and they're explaining why
uh
you know if you're a parent you should
be concerned about him going into a
restroom
with your young daughter he explains why
here it is
i hope everyone knows
that we need to protect the women and
children
has been used against marginalized
people
for most of human history these comments
upset me because it's anti-trans of
course but also it strikes me as
anti-your own daughters
anti-young people
anti-women
if you are a young person if you're a
daughter if you are a woman would you do
me a favor
please let all of the men in your life
know
that you can take care of yourself
let them know you don't need protecting
and that you especially don't want
protection
if it means erasing
trans people from public life
yes he says nothing creepy about that at
all the guy the man the dress here
says that no no don't don't worry about
protecting your daughter when i walk
into the restroom with her she doesn't
she can handle herself
that's what this guy is saying no no she
could take care of herself
and you know
this is coming from someone who uh
they're saying oh your your daughter she
could take care of herself she doesn't
need to be protected you don't need to
infantilize her you're infantilizing
your daughter by trying to stop grown
men in dresses
from walking into the bathroom and
potentially
abusing them
meanwhile this same person would say i'm
sure
that if you
use the wrong pronoun in his presence
you're causing him deep psychological
and even physical harm
so here's what he's actually saying
he's not saying
don't protect your daughter
everyone can handle themselves
that would be bad enough
but at least there'd be some consistency
to that
if his message is let everyone take care
of themselves
no what he's saying is what this man in
the dress and the lipstick and the and
the
goofy makeup
what he's saying is he's looking at you
and saying no prioritize protecting me
instead of your daughter
prioritize protecting my emotional and
mental well-being over the physical
health and safety of your daughter
that's actually what he's saying
he feels
think about where we are in society that
that a man would feel comfortable
it's one thing to think that way
but the man feels comfortable getting in
front of a camera and saying that out
loud
don't worry about protecting your
daughter it no it's me i'm i'm the one
you should worry about how i feel
because if you make me go in the the
men's bathroom i'm not gonna feel good
about that i won't feel good
your daughter might not feel good with a
grown man in the in the bathroom with
him
and she might actually be in physical
danger but don't worry about that worry
about me
he feels perfectly comfortable sitting
in front of a camera and saying that to
the public
he shouldn't
because that is a grotesque
uh
sentiment to say the very least
listen hit that subscribe button right
now
do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated